Matthew Perry beat up a future Prime
Minister got Bruce Willis to take a role
on a bet and once had his heart stop for
5 minutes after Perry's tragic passing
here's a look back at the most
fascinating stories from his
life it's hard to imagine Matthew Perry
doing anything other than making
audiences laugh because he's been doing
it for so long he got to start guest
starring on shows like Charles in Charge
in Silver Spoons and a memorable
recurring role on Growing Pains and has
since become synonymous with sitcoms
believe it or not though tennis was his
first serious ambition Perry had quite a
promising tennis career earlier in life
in his youth Perry was a highly ranked
player on the junior circuit in Canada
where he grew up and had real hopes of
turning pro his move to Los Angeles
changed things and gave him some
perspective he told Men's Health in 2012
giving up tennis wasn't really a
decision I had to make I was a very good
tennis player in Ottawa Canada
nationally ranked when I was like 13
then I moved to Los Angeles when I was
15 and everyone in La just killed me I
realized I wouldn't be playing tennis
for a living so I went for
acting in the 1990s Matthew Perry wasn't
just one of the biggest stars on TV he
was one of the biggest actors in
Hollywood period he and the rest of the
cast of Friends were bigger than just
about anyone and that meant that
everyone wanted to know who they were
dating over the years a few of Perry's
high-profile romances have been well
chronicled including his Time dating
Baywatch star Yasmine ble in
1995 you're just saying that cuz you're
in love with Yas Meine ble well how
could anyone not be in love with Yas
he also dated neev Campbell a few years
later Lizzy Kaplan in the late 2000s and
had a brief engagement to literary
manager Molly herwitz that was broken
off in 2020 what you may not recall are
some of his lesser known loves including
the Bold and the Beautiful star ma
quinland in 2002 a very brief romance
with Gilmore Girl star Lauren Graham A
year later and volleyball player Rachel
Dunn not long after but even more lesser
known are some of the famous women he
went out with that never turned into
relationships such as an Infamous
terrible first date with Cameron Diaz
Perry said in his Memoir friends lovers
and the big terrible thing that they
were set up on a date which ended when
Diaz accidentally punched Perry in the
face after he told a joke during a game
of Pictionary
whoops once he became a household name
on Friends it was another superstar that
Perry pursued beginning a relationship
with Superstar Julia Roberts as he
described to GQ in 2022 after the
publication of his Memoir his courtship
of Roberts was unbelievably romantic as
Perry detailed it all started when he
began chasing Roberts to be a guest star
on friends to his surprise the big
screen star showed interest but only if
her part would put her into a storyline
with Perry's Chandler Bing flattered
Perry realized that Roberts might have
an interest in more than just a guest
spot he first tried to woo her with a
traditional bouquet of roses to which
Perry got an unusual response she wanted
him to concisely explain quantum physics
to her and it wasn't a joke Perry
explained the following day I sent her a
paper all about wave particle duality
and the uncertainty PR principle and
entanglement and only some of it was
metaphorical they began flirting heavily
over facts of all things and before long
Roberts not only agreed to guest star
but she and Perry became a couple before
they even shot her guest
appearance like many stars and Ordinary
People alike Matthew Perry has had his
struggles with alcohol and drug
addiction which have been well
chronicled the actor admits that during
production on Friends he was rarely
sober with his substance use so bad that
he lived in rehab during part of the
show's run you know it's been pretty
well documented that I had some I had
some problems with alcoholism and and
addiction after years though Perry
finally focused on cleaning up his life
and he spent $9 million to see it
through more than a dozen surgeries were
required to save Perry's life over the
years including one the doctors told his
family he almost certainly wouldn't
survive Against All Odds Perry came out
the other side but to keep himself
healthy it cost him millions of dollars
he wrote in his Memoir I have been to
6,000 AA meetings I've been to rehab 15
times I've been in a mental institution
gone to therapy twice a week for 30
years been to death's St at one point
after his colon ruptured Perry's
problems were so bad they left him in a
coma he told people I was put on a thing
called an ECMO machine which does all
the breathing for your heart and your
lungs that's called a Hail Mary no one
survives that but survive Perry did and
at the time of his death he'd been sober
for nearly 3
years few would ever think of Matthew
Perry as a brute and certainly not the
kind of person who would go on National
Television telling stories about how he
smacked around the Canadian Prime
Minister yet in 2022 Perry did just that
though the important context is that
they were in grade school together Perry
told Jimmy Kimmel in 2017 that he and a
friend were jealous of Justin Trudeau
and well beat him up we actually uh beat
up Justin Trudeau you know I'm not
bragging about this is terrible I was a
stupid kid Kimmel pointed out that the
incident occurred when Trudeau's father
was the country's sitting prime minister
though it doesn't sound like Perry got
into any more serious trouble than your
average playground tusler as for Trudeau
himself the current prime minister
responded playfully challenging Perry to
a rematch two weeks after he' made the
remarks on Kimmel well timed for April
Fool's Day Perry humbly declined a
second
round friends was a show full of big
laughs from every member of the cast
each had a unique style of humor and
Matthew Perry was no exception but some
in the cast weren't always thrilled with
the jokes they were given in the script
either feeling they weren't funny or
didn't fit their character after all
playing these roles every week for years
the performers may know their characters
better than anyone and when Perry wanted
a different joke his tactic was to
sabotage the script in her book end
credits how I broke up with Hollywood
series writer Patty Lynn talked about
how the likes of Perry Jennifer Aniston
and Courtney Cox would ruin jokes
written in the script by intentionally
delivering them wrong or badly this
would often Force the crew to look for a
fix necessitating a rewrite with the
cast themselves often pitching in ideas
for new jokes the push back on what they
deemed as a bad joke wasn't always
helpful though even if they might have
made the show better especially to
writers like Lynn who said these
sessions had a dire aggressive quality
that lacked all the levity you'd expect
from the making of a
sitcom Matthew Perry suffered numerous
Health crises through the years which
are all well documented one of the most
horrific occurred while he was doing
another stinton rehab and Was preparing
for surgery for reported stomach pain
which required a dose of heavy
anesthesia according to Perry the drug
had actually stopped his heart for 5
full minutes he wrote I was told that
some beefy Swiss guy really didn't want
the guy from Friends dying on his table
and did CPR on me for the full five
minutes beating and pounding my chest I
got
CPR and the guy who saved my life broke
eight ribs the broken ribs required more
physical rehab this became a problem for
his next movie because he' just been
cast in a major role in Adam McKay's
don't look up as Perry recounts he was
initially to play a republican
journalist who who shares the screen
with Merill Streep in a few scenes and
it was heartbreaking to miss out on the
role for some fans Matthew Perry was the
heart and soul of friends with his
signature Wise Cracks becoming one of
the best things about the series you
didn't cry when Bambi's mother died yes
it was very sad when the GU stopped
drawing the deer believe it or not
though Matthew Perry almost missed out
on the chance to join the series in a
leading role not once but twice the
first obstacle was that Perry was
already committed to another project
when it came time to audition for the
series but I was off the market because
I had taken a job uh on a pilot called
LAX
2194 the series a Sci-Fi comedy
co-starring Kelly who and Ryan Styles
followed a group of baggage handlers
working in the Los Angeles International
Airport in the distant future in which I
had to sort out the aliens luggage and
that was basically the show the goofy
series pilot thankfully didn't impress
Network execs with one saying it was the
worst thing we've ever seen in our lives
suddenly Perry was available to audition
in the rest is history or so many may
think but the truth is Chandler and
Phoebe were originally intended to be
minor supporting characters thanks to
Perry and Lisa kudo's Talent however
that quickly changed friends had some
impressive recurring guest stars but few
storylines featured as big a name as
when we met Elizabeth's father Paul
played by Die Hard star Bruce Willis
even with the show's history of bigname
guest stars Willis's appearance was a
big deal and an even bigger one because
he stuck around for three whole episodes
you they say that Still Waters Run Deep
and I I want to swim in
yours are you talking about having sex
apparently Willis did it because he lost
a bet to Perry he and Willis met during
production of the film The Whole Nine
Yards during filming the two actors
bonded over their love of partying
between takes but during their fun
Willis expressed concerns that the film
was going to flop Perry disagreed and
the two made a wager if the movie was a
hit Willis had to do a guest spot on
Friends arriving in theaters in February
2000 the whole nine yards was number one
at the box office and route to a $16
million Hall more than double its 41
million do budget Willis got the last
laugh though as in addition to three
excellent episodes Willis took home an
Emmy Award for his performance as Paul
Stevens with the Triumph of the whole
nine yards Matthew Perry had a major
movie win and with friends coming to an
end not long after the actor likely saw
a path to a new career on the big screen
first up was a sequel the whole 10 yards
reuniting him with Bruce Willis for
another run at box office gold but the
follow-up was a major bomb and it's one
that made Perry completely reassess his
career as he wrote in his Memoir that
was the moment Hollywood decided to no
longer invite Mr Perry to be in movies
forced to re-evaluate his career Perry
used the failure of the whole 10 yards
to Pivot looking for Quality roles first
and foremost one of his next projects
was the Aaron sorcin created TV series
Studio 60 on the Sunset Strip which
arrived with major hype with many
thinking it was going to be the next big
hit
famously overshadowed by the similarly
themed 30 Rock from Tina Fay Studio 60
was canceled after just 1 year but that
didn't stop Perry turning to writing he
created Mr Sunshine in 2011 and go on in
2012 neither lasted but he made a major
comeback on The Odd Couple reboot in
2015 which had a solid three-season
[Music]
run